i've always been interested you know
hearing about ramadan and
and fasting but more recently
um i was learning a lot about like
meditation and fasting
and during this entire time i would pray
is there any words you would say for
those maybe there's people out there
like yourself you know
who are interested but they're a bit
hesitant um is there anything that you
would say to them
no the main thing for me was um
asking you know allah to to change me
[Music]
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in love
and my afro was picky to the nighties
moschino and versace no laces in her
cheeks
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome back to my channel
um i think i'll say about a couple of
days ago or a week ago i got um
a message from a sister uh in california
um i won't mention her name uh but she
couldn't contact me
and um i think she was interested in
islam so she wanted to take a shahada
and usually with this kind of stuff when
sisters contacted cause about two weeks
ago
and another sister in london contact me
also and then
we caught well um we got in contact with
her
we called her with my wife and she
accepted islam but um
this one we said you know what let's
have an interview maybe hear
the story behind the sister why she
wanted to accept his time so she's with
me uh
online uh salaam alaikum sister
hello how are you doing okay i'm okay
that's good okay so obviously
you want to accept islam and the shahada
takes about
10 20 seconds yeah and obviously it's a
life-changing moment
but before that um can you tell us a bit
about
where did you hear about islam where did
your interests build
uh ever i mean i've always heard about
it
um i've always been interested you know
hearing about ramadan and
and fasting but uh more recently
um i was learning a lot about like
meditation and fasting
and during this entire time i would um
pray
because i started working as a medical
assistant
but before that i was like an alcoholic
like i couldn't stop drinking and um you
know i would pray
to god only god never jesus even though
my parents are christian
and actually my stepfather's a pastor
but still i just never prayed to jesus i
just always spoke to god
and um and i feel like this entire time
he helped me
through my medical assisting classes and
get a job
and um but aside of that
like i was you know learning about the
fasting and the meditation
[Music]
and i was also meeting friends online
and they would always
like tell me stuff about islam and and
about marriage
like how it's how it's supposed to be um
what the prophet muhammad um
teaches and i just always thought it was
so beautiful
you know and um and then one of my
friends uh
because i was also wanting to learn
another language and he said
and while he teaches me about the quran
and um he was like you know you should
learn arabic so you can learn about
you know understand the crime better and
he also sent me your videos and then
okay your video
really helped me understand like all the
questions that i had
like you answered them and then i just
i decided you know that was it like i
need to do it
so how many how long was this like was
it like matter of years or months would
you say
this interest oh like the strong
interest
probably like a month or two i don't
know maybe
yeah hello like probably around
two months maybe a little bit less wow
wow that's that's amazing
um i came to california i think about a
year and a half ago
um it's we we came for an event
um and it was really beautiful it's a
really beautiful place
because i've been to new york and new
york's a bit like a bit like london
on steroids uh like times square is like
mad we have we have something similar to
time square but not as like big as that
but when i came to california it was
about nature and i really loved it it
was like nature and it was like
but they took us to a place where there
was like mountains and rivers and
stuff like that i really really liked it
and um i went to because i'm a big fan
of uh
you know macaroons yeah yeah
yeah yeah so yeah we went to one of
these places and that was the best
macaroons i've had in my life so
uh so yeah we went there we did a talk
it was good uh it was amazing
and hopefully definitely would love to
come back
um and so that's that's
that's really amazing you know to know
uh that to because to us like here we
just you know obviously we do videos to
inspire people
and share our journey because i came to
islam about seven seven eight years ago
myself as well
and knowing the lifestyle that we lived
before you know
and when you come to islam you really
really value and appreciate because
a lot of muslims that are born into it
they don't i wouldn't say all but
not many of them really appreciate it
but the ones who experience the other
side
of the life the dark side um you know
and the things that you go for you
genuinely do not find
that happiness you know it's all these
things that you know you
uh try to follow and
especially as a female you know there's
a lot of females that come to islam
and i was reading a book called beauty
sick
it's called beauty sick and it's quite
interesting you know because it talks
about
you know the females and the the
pressure that they have on them as a
society
you know you're made to feel ugly you
have to look this way or that way
plastic surgery
you know you can't come out of the house
if you don't have makeup and it's the
pressure it's it's
and it made me think like you know what
it makes perfect sense why a lot of
women come to islam uh you know because
it really
breaks those shackles those invisible
shackles that are a lot of this goes
with men as well you know because like
before me myself as well
you know i was really caught with my
looks and i have to look like this way
you know um i used to i would go
clubbing and i would have to wear this
specific jumper because i believe that i
looked really good in it but i
was so uncomfortable it was those it was
that material that would itch you
and but i wore it because i looked good
and i was like
i thought to myself if like i'm
literally a slave this
this jump is my master i'm a slave to
this my master and i'm just serving it
even though i hate it and i dislike it
and it's the same with you know like
some females that might be wearing high
heels and they're not comfortable
and all that being the makeup or you
have to look certain way
and being called you know you're seen as
like some kind of a
an object you know and you're not happy
with your body you know it's it's
it's all these factors and when you come
to islam like
you break those shackles you don't
really care like me personally i said
look i don't care what anyone thinks of
me like
you just come to that freedom where and
it's amazing it's it's
it's this it's uplifting you know um and
you will definitely taste that you know
when you come to islam you would know
what i'm talking about but probably you
probably
are already you know um and that's why
it's really um
important you know for us to come and
understand
that we as human beings we're all bound
to be a slave to something like that's
in our nature
you know we're bound it's either going
to be money is it going to be society
or peer pressure or proving yourself
dear friends and these are all
enslavement because if you're not truly
living for yourself
and you're living for others where
you're you're actually enslaved
and i came to the realization of okay if
i'm going to be a slave
i want to be a slave to something that
deserves it you know
and that's when i found my true freedom
i said okay if i'm going to be enslaved
to money
or cars or girls or family like i have
to prove something to anyone
well they're not deserving of my
enslavement if i'm gonna do it
let me do it to the one who created me
because he's deserving of it
and in that moment of enslavement i
found my true freedom
by worshiping him alone and yeah you
know
um sorry i'm you know i'm really i'm
really
happy and um it really keeps me going
you know to know
that all the way from uk to california
that our videos
you know be it me muhammad hijab and the
rest that you know
it plays a massive role to someone and
what's your background sister
uh well i'm mexican so mexican yeah
yeah because i don't know any latino or
yeah i don't know any muslims like at
all
any no okay so
i'm gonna get you in contact because if
i'm a mistake in california there is
uh there is we know because we came
there there was a lot of big muslim
community
we're gonna get you in contact with some
sisters definitely i'm going to get you
um in contact with some if the bay area
right
yeah yeah i know there's one here in my
town actually
there's one here in my town yeah um
yeah but like i just feel funny like
going alone and i don't know the customs
but i reached out to them but i i will
go i'm just like
and maybe this will give me the place to
go now i was i was like that i was like
that before i came to istanbul i was so
scared to go into a mosque i dropped i
would keep driving past it i was like
i don't know shall i go in shall i go in
so i know exactly how you feel it's like
yeah but don't worry what we're gonna
get we're gonna make sure there's gonna
be sisters you know
beforehand maybe they can come meet you
somewhere coffee or whatever
and take it step out of time inshallah
and i wanna pick my daughters
uh i have two daughters um and you know
one i have one daughter
she's older she's like okay but that's
not for me you know she doesn't know
much and my little one
she she believes in jesus and so now
when i tell her about islam she's like
feeling confused but i want to bring her
like i was like can you go to the mosque
with me and she said fine i will so i
just think she's going to fall in love
with it i just really do
that's i'm hoping you come with me
that's amazing you know
you know one thing you should bear in
mind as well is i say this to a lot of
reavers who come to islam
that it might be that allah has chosen
you as an ambassador to your family
so it might be that it's through you
that there's other people in your family
that's going to come to islam
uh because you know like you see a lot
of reverts who come to islam and
they end up being the ones who deliver
the message of islam to their family
members
um and allah tells us in the quran you
know save yourself and your family from
the fire first so before preaching
to the whole world start from the family
so your journey you might be
you are most likely an ambassador to
your family to your daughters obviously
your job is to convey the message you
can't force anybody
and in islam it's you know it's
forbidden to force i'm sure you're not
gonna do that
right now actually uh my partner is um
it has brought us closer well like like
he's even reminding me to pray and we'll
do it together
and and we don't really know what we're
doing just yet but you know i google it
and i youtube
so you and your okay well let me get
this right you and your partner is your
partner's not muslim
no so you both are praying together
um yeah wow well i guess you can
consider himself one
you know um but actually before anything
he used to uh
teach me about um like the nation of
islam and i kind of started there a
little bit
because i figured i should go to the
source this is not like
the source i would say yes
stay away from them right well that's
how it started too
i was like learning about that well
exactly so but it's
it's it's amazing you know it's so you
and your husband you're both muslim and
you're
watching these videos and trying to pray
together right that is amazing that is
so
amazing it's it's it's it's overwhelming
and i'm sure people that are watching
this
it's the effort that you're going
through you know and i see
a lot of reverts that haven't even come
to islam i was i met one
who was fasting for like two years the
guy was fasting he was praying
he was doing everything and i was like
have you took a shower is that no oh
that brother
it's it's amazing the the love that they
have for it
um and yeah definitely so if it's both
you and your husband
that's good because what that means is
because usually
as a female when you accept islam you're
not you're not allowed
to be married to somebody that's not
muslim but
you don't have that so that's great and
yeah when he told me i was like ah
but but it's good that yeah your
husband's on board because sometimes
the opposite partner can make it
difficult but that's i'm so happy to
hear that
um yeah so so okay so you're gonna okay
you're gonna take a shahada
inshallah and what about your husband
or your partner um i i think he has
i think he is a little bit um hesitant
for now no problem okay no problems you
never know he might take a shahadah with
you
so yeah okay no problem um
is there anything else you want to see
before we start
um no just thank you for taking the time
no no it's a pleasure like you know if
there's anyone watching this video
if wherever in the world you are as you
can see we're speaking to a sister in
california
it's an honor it's a pleasure for us to
have this it's absolutely an honor you
know the fact that
um allah's enabled and chose us like for
me personally
to be the one that's going to be a
witness to that and we ask allah to
accept it from us
and to purify intentions that we do for
the right reasons
um because this whole shahada thing
sometimes it can be glorified in the
context of you know like
uh you know but it's really important
for us to do it for the right reasons um
so yeah um you can repeat after me if
you're ready
right i'm ready okay
anna
[Music]
i bear witness okay good
i bear witness i bear witness
there is nothing that there is nothing
worthy of worship worthy of worship
accept allah accept allah and i bear
witness
and i bear witness that muhammad
that muhammad peace be upon him peace be
upon him is his
servant is his servant and his messenger
and his mercy welcome to islam
thank you usually with this instance
usually
i wish their sister's there so you can
go and give them a hug but we're going
to arrange that so
keep the hugs and the tears ready um
because we're going to make sure we've
got team there and we're going to make
sure they come and meet you
and see this as a journey sister it's
like a key that's given to you
and the doors open now and this is going
to be your journey
um our aim is not to reach the end of
the path
but it's to die on the path um so you
know
as long as we're on the path and we're
striving and we're all going to be
tested
you know allah is going to test you he
will test you know i've been tested as
well
be strong be firm um handle you've got a
supporting husband
and we're going to make sure that you
have a community and myself
my wife we're always here for you
whenever you want if you don't ever
hesitate
whatever time it is don't hesitate if
there's anything you need uh whatever it
may be
we're gonna do it and also we're gonna
get you in contact with an organization
here called i
error i don't know if you heard of them
no okay so they will give
hopefully i think they can send it to
america as well as starter pack for new
muslims
so something like about for example it
will equip you with a lot of stuff and
your husband as well
um if your husband does come around and
if you
you know want to take you can you could
do with you but if not
get in contact we can do it's not a
problem at all um
and if there's anything you need to stay
inshaallah please contact me whatever
question you have it can be about salah
it can be about quran
if there's questions you want to ask
whatever it may be sister we're at your
service
and may allah bless you i'm really
really happy that you know and feel
honored
that you wanted to take the shahada with
me
may allah bless you you know i was like
uh
yeah i was like you helped me understand
it and i just feel like
yeah this would be an honor to also do
it with you so thank you
no no may allah bless you allah so salah
wise do you know how to pray
like do you have a gist sort of i don't
think i'm doing a great job at it but i
figure i'm going to
learn in time no problem so what we will
do is inshallah i'm going to message you
the details of the organization well the
brothers and sisters who are there
and we're going to get in contact with
you inshallah and they will teach you
how to pray they will teach you how to
do wudu
uh they'll take you to the masjid you
can see the if is it open in california
because of the lockdown
now i don't know i heard that only the
men can go but they do it outside
okay all right so hopefully when it's
open if not i don't have the lockdown
regulations there but if they can maybe
come
we'll see they'll arrange something but
they'll make sure that definitely you
can learn the whole thing and take it
step by step do not rush
um slowly slowly develop yourself
inshallah
and it's a journey it's just started and
keep you firm
um and yeah may allah bless you is there
any words you would say for those
maybe there's people out there like
yourself you know who are interested but
they're a bit hesitant
um is there anything that you would say
to them
um i just you know the main thing for me
was
um asking you know allah to
to change me so because i have so many
still
like oh i don't know if i want to do the
hijab and you know but i just asked him
to change me
to to in that just come sincere
you know i pray and and i just come with
my sincerity
to ask you know that he will he will
change me
uh because a lot of people don't want to
be changed i think that's the main thing
you know
step by step and and i'm not perfect you
know nobody is
and all i can do is try exactly exactly
sister you know that's
that's amazing you know at the end of
the day your dua
is the prophet sallallahu asallam taught
us that dua is the most powerful thing
for a believer so asking allah what if
it maybe it might be something small you
know
just ask i'm being honest it's something
so small which i came to the realization
of
you know i was discussing this with the
brothers as well i bought my wife a
cupboard
um like wardrobe like a wardrobe is that
what you call it
yeah so i bought and i was i was trying
to do and i thought to myself logically
you know i need
a screwdriver and i was doing it and i
did it but the legs broke and i was so
frustrated
but i've came to myself i thought to
myself you know what we think
like with these things okay i just need
a screwdriver and i can do it myself
but asking allah's help in even small
things it must be small
but allah literally makes things easy so
when you're asking for dua
whatever it may be whatever it can be
a driving test or whatever it may be ask
allah make
and it's so powerful because this is
what this is about you know this is who
our lord is
and we are acknowledging it's a form of
worship to know that you need his help
in the most smallest of the big things
and keep him as your companion
you know allah will always always get
you out
allah this is allah's promise you know
if you fear him he will get you out of
places you could never imagine
and allah works in mysterious ways and
you i'm sure have witnessed that because
i've witnessed that myself as well
i'm not going to hold you further i know
probably you need to
maybe your kids are wearing at home i'm
so sorry for going on but may allah
bless you thank you for your time
um california i'm sure you've got
beautiful weather we've got um
rain here as usual um and storm
that i asked you about on the way so i
got it now
it's called uh now i don't remember what
it's called um the woman in the text
i found the name of it yes it was you
was asking me right
the woman yeah it's on the way so i
ordered it yes yes did you get it i
ordered it
it's on the way from amazon yeah oh
brilliant yes that's my teachers the
woman in the text yeah
brilliant brilliant book he's gonna he's
gonna be so happy when he sees this i
i told him about it he was over the moon
he was like really i was like yeah he's
like your book
and yes um may god bless you so i got
that
that's great i'm gonna try to get you
another book it's
from sister lauren booth um her journey
to islam
it's quite interesting um yeah
definitely we'll send you all the
equipment you need
stuff you need inshallah until yeah next
time look after yourself may allah bless
you give salaam to your husband as well
thank you